>>There's distribution and--
>>Do you wanna start
on that one first?
>>Yeah, we'll start on distribution.
There's a water cycle website.
Check out what the
interactive water cycle is.
>>Computer: Water on the earth
is constantly on the move.
It recycles over and--
>>This is good.
>>That's nice, we could do that to
introduce it, right, don't you think?
>>Katie: Teachers had created this
wealth of resources, of lesson plans,
of ideas, of different ways
to teach different concepts.
And we wanted to find a way where we
could share those ideas with teachers
from across our district,
and even teachers
from across the state,
and hopefully beyond.
>>All: -- is the most
important thing--
>>Katie: So the first thing
that we did is we calendared our
objectives, our state standards.
The second thing that we did was,
we gave teachers a common plan time.
>>Kevin: So we said, 'How can we
take our process that's proven
and make it kinda digitized
to make it more efficient?'
We took this free open source
product called MindTouch
and we created a collaborative Wiki.
>>Katie: We created what
we call Beyond Textbooks,
and it's an internet application
where teachers can take those
wonderful ideas and they can post it
on a Wiki page that is dedicated to
that concept and that content area.
>>Beyond Textbooks
really helps for prep.
During the week, it's
my first go to thing.
I know that there's always gonna be
something I can depend on on there.
>>We could probably--
maybe we could white out.
>>Yeah, perfect.
>>And have them fill it
in as they're watching.
>>And define it too, I'm thinking.
>>Kevin: Not only are we able
to use that for our own teachers
in our districts, so that they have
a central repository they can go
to to find all these teacher
resources, but now we've been able
to allow other school
districts to tap into it.
>>Sarah: A lot of the kids will say,
'Miss Bates, did you create that?
That's so cool.'
And, you know, I'll have
to say, 'Another teacher
at another school made this.
Isn't this so neat?
You know, there's other kids who
are able to look at this too.
Other kids are learning the
same thing that you are.'
And then they feel a
sense of connectedness
to other students at
our school district.
>>Crystal: Oh my goodness,
boys and girls.
[ rhythmic clapping ]
>>Kirsten: Now they have more posts
than they ever dreamed
they would have.
And now with all these schools
joining, we're getting lots
of new information from
outside of the district
that we've never had before.
>>Teaching is such
an isolated endeavor.
We want-- we don't want
you alone on an island.
We wanna let you know
there's other folks out there
that you can collaborate
with and discuss things with
and help each other, so that you
can help each others' students.